Das wäre möglich - mit Solarautos.
Ich hab wieder Saadet losgeschickt,
unsere rasende Reporterin,
oder auch, wie ihr sie nennt,
unsere "Mainautin"
oder "MaiLab-Stuntfrau"!
Ich war in Belgien
bei der "European Solar Challenge",
das ist quasi die EM für Solarautos.
Und da habe ich sogar
'n Solarauto-Unfall überlebt!
(Aufprallgeräusch)
(Funksprüche)
Ich brauche 'ne Bauchbinde: "Saadet,
überlebte einen Solarautounfall"
(Gelächter)
- Ja, das mach ich!
Und da habe ich sogar
'n Solarauto-Unfall überlebt!
Dazu kommen wir auch gleich noch.
Aber erst mal: Wie funktionieren
Solarautos eigentlich?
Wer sind die Menschen,
die diese Autos bauen?
Und ist es wirklich nachhaltig?
Also, macht es euch gemütlich!
Wir schauen uns heute an,
wie die Zukunft
auf unseren Straßen aussieht.
(Titelmelodie)
Untertitel: ARD Text für Funk (2018)
Die "European Solar Challenge"
ist kein gewöhnliches Rennen:
1. Die Autos sind Solarautos.
Und 2. Das Rennen
dauert ganze 24 Stunden.
Es kommt also nicht darauf an, wer
als erstes über die Ziellinie fährt,
sondern wer
die meisten Kilometer schafft.
Und dafür kommen die Leute
auch nicht nur aus Europa,
sondern aus der ganzen Welt.
We're from Italy, Sicily.
I'm from the Netherlands.
Istanbul! Turkey.
We're from the UK.
Poland
Colombia.
France.
Australia! Wouh!
Und alle haben ihre Autos dabei.
Bzw. die Teile ihrer Autos.
Und Tage vorher
sind alle damit beschäftigt,
die Autos zusammenzubauen
und alles vorzubereiten.
Bzw. sind die Bochumer
sogar mit manchen ihrer Autos
direkt über die Autobahn hingefahren.
Das war dann natürlich
ein riesen Spektakel.
Ich habe vorher auch noch
nie so 'n "spacy Auto" gesehen.
D.h. die Leute
machen dann auch Fotos und so,
das ist teils
sogar ein bisschen gefährlich.
Aber es kamen alle sicher an.
- Mein Lieblingsauto war ja dieses
ganz flache, wo da nur so 'n...
- Nur in der Mitte dieses Ding, ja!
(lacht)
- Was ist dieses Flache? - Das ist
eins der Tischtennis-Autos.
Mit der Anreise alleine war es
aber leider noch nicht getan.
Die Leute hatten vor Ort
noch so viel zu tun,
mit Reparaturen
und Zusammenbasteln usw.,
dass sie wirklich direkt neben
der Rennstrecke einen Campingplatz
für alle Teilnehmer hatten, damit sie
ganz nah an ihren Autos waren.
Also ein Science Engineering Camp!
Find ich gut.
Ihr seid ja hier irgendwie
ein richtig durchgemixtes Team.
Studiert ihr alle das gleiche?
Oder ist es so eine Art AG,
und jeder kann mitmachen?
Also wir studieren bei weitem nicht
alle das gleiche!
An unserer Hochschule gibt es
x verschiedene Fachbereiche,
und irgendwie
sind annähernd alle vertreten.
Wir haben auch mittlerweile
mehrere Hochschulen dabei,
auch 'ne Design-Hochschulen.
Wir haben auch Medienleute,
genauso wie wir Wirtschaftler haben.
Und wir sagen auch immer:
Man muss nicht wirklich was können,
nur die Motivation mitbringen,
den Rest bringen wir allen bei.
Man muss also
keine großen Erfahrungen haben
oder irgendwas speziell
studiert haben, um mitzumachen.
- Dann kann ich auch mitmachen!
- Auf jeden Fall!
Wer Spaß hat, soll mitmachen. Und
dann finden wir genügend Aufgaben.
- Das ist übrigens Christian
von der Hochschule Bochum.
Seine Aufgabe ist es,
die Abläufe zu koordinieren.
Also dass etwas, womit man
nicht rechnet, passieren wird,
das ist eigentlich recht sicher.
(lacht)
Wir sind am Abend vorher
an der Rennstrecke angekommen.
Jetzt seh' ich aus wie ihr.
Jetzt denken alle,
ich könnte auch Autos bauen.
- Ja, das kannst du ja theoretisch
auch, das kann jeder! - Jeder? Ok.
Da wurde noch rumgebastelt,
da wurden noch Autos probegefahren
und Sachen wurden teilweise noch
auf den letzten Drücker repariert.
Also, geschlafen
haben die Leute da eher wenig.
Stell dir hier ein Solarcar vor
und da ein Solarcar.
Aber die sind ja gerade
auf der Strecke unterwegs.
Moment! Warum fahren Solarautos
eigentlich auch nachts?
Alle Autos hier
sind auch "Elektroautos"!
D.h. sie fahren auf Batterie.
Das ist ein Elektroauto,
was die Solarzellen
als eine Art "Range-Extender",
wenn man so will, dabei hat,
das quasi den Tank während der Fahrt
wieder befüllen kann.
Es sind übrigens dieselben Batterien
wie in unseren Handys oder Laptops:
Die bestehen aus 2 Elektroden.
Die positive Elektrode besteht aus
'ner Lithium-Metall-Verbindung,
z.B. Lithiumcobaltoxid.
Die Negativ-Elektrode
besteht aus Graphit,
das man neuerdings
mit "f" schreiben soll.
Nee, nee, das sieht komisch aus.
Egal!
Zwischen den Elektroden
ist eine leitende Flüssigkeit,
der Elektrolyt.
Durch den Elektrolyten
können sich geladene Teilchen,
z.B. Lithium-Ionen, bewegen.
Wenn ich die Batterien lade,
sammeln sich Elekronen im Grafit,
und Lithium-Ionen,
aus dem Lithiumcobaltoxid,
gesellen sich dazu.
In einer chemischen Reaktion,
namens "Reduktion",
verbinden sich Lithium-Ionen
und Elektronen
zu Lithium-Atomen.
Benutzt man die Batterie,
kehrt sich die chemische Reaktion um:
Aus Reduktion wird Oxidation.
Dabei werden wieder Elektronen frei,
die dann den Strom,
das Auto, befreien,
während die Lithium-Ionen
wieder in den Flusspol zurückkehren.
Nachts fahren die Autos
also auf Batterie.
Damit wir die dann nicht aufbrauchen,
müssen wir natürlich
immer entsprechend fahren.
Das ist auch das Spannende
an dem 24-Stunden-Rennen,
weil wir eben nur die Hälfte davon
auch bei Sonnenlicht fahren. - Ja.
Morgens wurde erst einmal in großer
Runde gemeinsam auf dem Campingplatz
gefrühstückt.
Das war auch ganz witzig, wie die
Leute da aus ihren Zelten krochen,
mega durch. Und ich: "Hallo, ich
halte dir 'ne Kamera ins Gesicht!"
Auf der Rennstrecke
selbst war das Chaos groß.
Da wurde noch herumgeschraubt,
Reifen wurden gewechselt,
Sachen wurden noch neu programmiert
und auseinandergenommen.
Und Leute lagen noch unter Autos
und haben Sachen
auf den letzten Drücker
gerade gerückt.
Und dann ging's plötzlich los.
- Go, go, go!
Tatsächlich habe ich mir diesen Start
etwas spektakulärer vorgestellt.
Es ist ja so ein bisschen
langsam angerollt.
Auf einmal haben sich
da alle versammelt,
und dann sind die
dahin gerannt zu den Autos.
Sind dann erst einmal
so losgetuckert.
(Applaus und Jubel)
Und ich so:
War das jetzt der Start? (Lachen)
Aber es ist ja eigentlich
auch logisch.
Ich meine, die müssen
24 Stunden da durchfahren.
Es macht keinen Sinn,
da am Anfang direkt
die ganze Energie raus zu hauen.
Und es ist ein bisschen ironisch,
weil wirklich ungefähr
genau mit dem Startschuss
hat es angefangen zu regnen.
Und es hat dann auch einfach
nicht mehr aufgehört.
Aber ich habe gelernt: Solarzellen
funktionieren auch bei Regen.
Für Solarzellen
braucht man Materialien,
die man Halbleiter nennt.
Silizium wäre so ein Material.
Silizium leitet Strom - so halb halt!
Um zu verstehen,
wie man Strom halb leiten kann,
lasst uns erst einmal anschauen,
welche Stoffe Strom leiten
und welche Strom nicht leiten.
So, jetzt wird's
'n bisschen chemisch!
Alle Stoffe sind ja
aus Atomen aufgebaut.
Und alle Atome haben einen Kern,
umhüllt von Elektronen.
Nehmen wir mal ein Metall:
Das ist so aufgebaut, das besteht
natürlich aus Metall-Atomen.
Aber die äußeren Elektronen der
Metall-Atom sind nicht fest gebunden,
sondern können sich frei in dem
ganzen Metall herum bewegen.
Man nennt das auch Elektronen-Gas.
Deshalb leiten Metalle Strom, der ja
nichts anderes ist als Elektronen.
Doch bei Kohlenstoff z.B.
sitzen die Elektronen
in den Bindungen fest.
Sie sind nicht beweglich.
Und deswegen leitet Kohle
auch keinen Strom.
Halbleiter, wie z.B. Silizium,
die können Strom leiten.
Oder auch nicht, das ist z.B.
abhängig von der Temperatur.
Aber man kann die Leitfähigkeit von
Silizium auch gezielt einstellen.
Indem man das Silizium mit einer
Prise eines anderen Elements würzt.
Wenn man in ein Silizium-Gitter
hier und da
ein paar Phosphor-Atome einbaut,
bekommt man dadurch eine Art
dünnes Elektronen-Gas.
Jedes Phosphor-Atom hat
ein Elektron mehr, als Silizium.
Diese überflüssigen Elektronen
braucht man nicht für die Bindungen.
Die können sich stattdessen
einfach frei bewegen.
Und dieses würzen mit Phosphor
nennt man:
Man kann aber auch positiv dotieren.
Indem man,
statt ein paar Phosphor-Atome,
ein paar Bohr-Atome nimmt.
Bohr hat nämlich ein Elektron
weniger als Silizium.
So entstehen Elektronen-Löcher.
Die kann man im Endeffekt
als positive Ladung verstehen.
Positiv dotiertes Silizium ist also
ein Leiter für positive Ladungen.
Damit haben wir schon die Basics
für eine Solarzelle.
Eine Solarzelle
ist folgendermaßen aufgebaut:
wir nehmen einen Siliziumskristall,
bei dem die eine Hälfte negativ, die
andere Hälfte positiv dotiert ist.
An der Übergangsschicht
passiert folgendes:
Die negativen Elektronen und die
positiven Löcher rekombinieren.
Und löschen sich gegenseitig aus,
wenn man so will.
Wo die negativen Elektronen
verschwinden,
bleibt eine positive Ladung zurück.
Wo die positiven Löcher verschwinden,
bleibt eine negative Ladung zurück.
Und so bekommen wir
eine elektrische Spannung,
genau wie mit einer Batterie
und ihrem Plus- und Minus-Polen.
Und jetzt kommt Sonnenlicht.
Mit ihrer Energie,
die diese Elektronen-Lochpaare
wieder trennen kann.
So entstehen wieder
Elektronen und Löcher,
die Elektronen werden abgefangen und
als Strom durch das Auto geleitet.
Und rekombinieren am Ende
wieder mit ihren Löchern.
Jetzt sind wir hier bei der
European Solar Challenge.
Die World Solar Challenge
findet immer in Australien statt.
Und da ist die Sonne eine ziemlich
ordentliche Unterstützung.
Man bekommt in Australien 600 km
reine Batterieleistung.
Und wenn man die Solarzellen
komplett nutzt,
dann schafft man bis zu 1000 km.
Ich persönlich finde
die Vorstellungs saucool,
dass wir vielleicht
in ein paar Jahren schon
Abgas-frei
durch die Städte fahren können.
Aber ich habe mich gefragt,
ob die Herstellung der Solarzellen
oder Batterien wirklich
so nachhaltig sind, wie man denkt.
In der Herstellungsphase ist
ein E-Autos oder v.a. ein Solarauto
sehr Energie-intensiv.
Im Verbrauch hinterher
sind wir sehr emissionsarm.
Die Jungs und Mädels haben mir
erklärt, dass sie für ihre Autos
verschiedene Solarzellen benutzen.
Es gibt grundsätzlich
zwei Arten von Solarzellen:
Einmal Silizium
und einmal Gallium-Arsenid.
Siliziumszellen sind
auf den Hausdächern verbaut.
Ähm...
Die sind wesentlich umweltschonender.
Allerdings ist Gallium-Arsenid
wesentlich effizienter.
Da muss man halt abwägen.
Es muss an so viel gedacht werden,
an das Material, wo das herkommt,
wo das produziert wird.
Da ist echt so eine Riesenkette
an Sachen dahinter,
die man echt noch
berücksichtigen muss.
Diese Batterieherstellung,
da wird unglaublich
viel Energie für verwendet.
Je nachdem, welche
Batteriezellen wir verwenden,
werden wir 7-8000 dieser
kleinen Rundzellen verbauen.
Das sind natürlich
massenhafte Batteriezellen.
Es ist nicht so eine
kleine Autobatterie,
sondern es ist so ein Oschi.
Und wiegt über 60 Kilo.
Als unsere Batterien nehmen einen...
in unserer CO2 Bilanz
einen großen Teil ein.
zum Beispiel muss man auch schauen,
wo der Strom, mit denen man
die Batterien belehrt, herkommt.
Und auch, was mit dem Strom ist,
den man braucht,
um die Autos herzustellen.
Zum Beispiel, in Australien kommt
sehr viel Strom noch aus Braunkohle.
Ist also sehr emissionsstark.
Da wäre es nachhaltig, das Ganze
nach Skandinavien zu verlegen,
wo vieles aus Wasserkraft kommt.
Für das Bochumer Team ist jedenfalls
klar, sie müssen die ganze Kette
bzw. die ganzen Vernetzungen
im Auge behalten.
Um wirklich nachhaltige Lösungen
zu schaffen.
Z.B. achten Sie auch
auf nachhaltige Rohstoffe,
wie zum Beispiel Naturfasern,
Holz, Ananas-Leder.
Was denkst du,
wie lange wird es noch dauern,
bis wir auch Solarautos
auf den Straßen sehen?
Hm... Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was auch noch ein Problem ist, ist,
dass die Solarzellen
sehr empfindlich sind.
Man kann die nicht anfassen,
hast du ja bestimmt
auch gemerkt beim Hochheben.
Darf ich die anfassen?
Das ist bei einem handelsüblichen
Auto einfach nicht praktisch.
Weil die werden dreckig,
da kommt Hagel drauf,
da kommt Regen drauf.
Und ich glaube,
wenn dieser Schritt überwunden ist,
zum einen dieser Schritt,
und zum anderen,
dass die ein
bisschen umweltfreundlicher
produziert werden können,
ich glaube, dann sind wir ganz
schnell bei Solarautos.
Also, es ist...
Kriegen wir das noch mit?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Es ist Quatsch, jetzt,
von heute auf morgen
alle Verbrenner
durch Elektroautos zu ersetzen.
Aber ein schrittweiser Umstieg, und
vor allem jetzt in den Großstädten,
sowas wie den Zweitwagen,
den ja einige Haushalte haben,
schon mal auszutauschen,
das ist durchaus machbar.
Wenn man sich einfach mal
die Verfügbarkeit
von fossilen Brennstoffen
und den Verbrauch dieser anguckt,
das kann man sich auf ein Blatt
Papier selber aufmalen,
da braucht man gar kein
großer Mathematiker für sein.
Um irgendwann einen
Break-Even-Point zu finden,
wo man sagt, okay, hier ist weg.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall
noch viel zu tun.
Aber das tun sie,
und sie haben Spaß dabei.
Das coole ist ja
die Stimmung vor Ort.
Weil es ist jetzt kein
totaler Konkurrenzkampf.
Sondern, eher im Gegenteil, da ist...
da findet
wissenschaftlicher Austausch statt.
Und man leiht sich irgendwie
gegenseitig Ersatzteile,
die mehrere 1000 Euro kosten.
Und alle haben irgendwie Spaß und
arbeiten zusammen an einer Sache.
Obwohl es an verschiedenen Autos ist.
Aber alle wollen halt irgendwie
ein cooles Endprodukt.
Und das war echt spannend, ja,
halt zu sehen.
Wir durften sogar
ein paar Runden mitfahren.
Wegen des Regens gab es sogar
einen kleinen Zwischenfall.
Wir sind nämlich, glaube ich,
so 50 oder so da lang gedüst.
Und in der Kurve sind wir einfach
von der Fahrbahn abgekommen.
Und plötzlich dreht sich das Ding
ohne Vorwarnung.
Und auf einmal stehen wir da
auf diesem Seitenstreifen.
Und ich nur so:
* Gerumpel *
Ja, da war zu schnell.
I went too fast.
V.a. dachte ich aber auch,
Scheiße, die Armen, die haben
so viel Arbeit reingesteckt.
Und ich dachte,
das Ding wäre halt kaputt.
Und dann war erst mal kurz Stille.
Und dann sind die
einfach weiter gefahren.
Und dies so: Ja, passiert schon mal,
haben mal ganz kurz
locker per Funk durchgegeben,
dass sie da ein bisschen was
verloren haben, oder so.
So, wir haben uns einmal
in der Schikane MP 5 gedreht.
Ein Fairing ist dabei flöten
gegangen, aber ansonsten läuft es.
Und da habe ich sogar einen
Solarauto-Unfall überlebt.
Also Saadet, du hast
deinem Namen als Stunt-Frau,
maiLab-Stunt-Frau alle Ehre gemacht.
Unfreiwillig.
- Vielen Dank dafür.
Und falls ihr noch Vorschläge habt,
was Saadet als nächstes
in Action machen kann,
dann schreibt es
in die Kommentare unter:
Phuuh! - Okay.
Nimmst du das nicht ernst, oder wie?
Aber, halt, Stopp!
Noch nicht weg gehen,
wir haben noch in der Endcut
eine Abstimmung für euch.
Nach unserem Video über Schlafmangel
gab es sehr viele Fragen
von euch zu Schlaf.
Deswegen gibt es nächste Woche
ein Video
zu dem Thema "Eulen vs. Lärchen",
also Frühaufsteher vs. Spätaufsteher.
Und auch Spät-, lange Wachbleiber.
Für dieses Video bitte ich euch,
hier oben abzustimmen. Zweimal.
Erstens, was seid ihr,
Eulen oder Lärchen.
Seid ihr Tag- oder Nacht-Menschen.
Und was glaubt ihr, was ich bin?
Die Auflösung gibt es
nächsten Montag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)